yeah
serious yes I love it uh let it bathe
over me Let It wash over me oh it feels
so good
sorry it's Thursday which means
tomorrow's Friday and then the weekend
and my friends say I learned nothing at
Berkeley
I love a good calendar
so the CDC needs a makeover worse than
Joy Behar
CDC stands for the Centers for Disease
Control but what did it control really
during the pandemic nothing instead it
became another bloated arm of the
bureaucratic machine a political entity
making political pronouncements and
protecting its political allies so no
surprise during the pandemic they were
more of a crap show than a leaky Fleet
enema
foreign
so they need to change and we're not
talking a half-assed transition I'm
talking at 100 Bruce to Caitlyn makeover
[Applause]
add a think tank agrees with me saying
the CDC needs a full reset because it no
longer can be trusted to handle Global
pandemics hell at this point it can't be
trusted to handle an outbreak of
dandruff or athlete's foot I wouldn't
trust them to cure disco fever
yeah they call everything a health
threat from racism to climate change
according to them anything that they
don't like could be a health risk how
convenient is that I'm surprised they
aren't demanding warning labels on
Republicans
and yet they miss the things that are
killing us by the millions no wonder the
Obesity epidemic has gotten out of
control
oh that picture must have showed up by
accident
although somebody get them more oats
the center for strategic and
International Studies or service
States the CDC has entered a moment of
peril and has suffered a sharp decline
in popular trust and confidence
but wait are we talking about the CDC or
just about everything these days that
one line could apply to every major
institution well except for the Gutfeld
Institute for awesome quads and abs
yeah you can still trust him
good people an excellent Whirlpool baths
lots of privacy if you know what I mean
but it's true the cdc's handling a covet
really put it on the map the same way
JFK's assassination put dealy Plaza on
the map
yeah it is a stretch the report also
suggests it needs to change how it
collects data and be more flexible with
its budget wow that's brilliant that's
like saying Jeffrey Dahmer's problem was
his choice of condiments
the report adds a CDC reset is a matter
of National Security the leadership
needs to prove its head is fully in the
reform game but true power to change
lies at the White House which means they
want the CDC to move its headquarters
from Atlanta to DC and why so Joe Biden
could screw it up from the comfort of
his own acorn stairlift
a move to Washington only makes sense if
you think carjacking is a great way to
meet strangers
so while I agree that the CDC is as bad
as the diseases it's meant to control
I'm not sure heading to the land of
grift and senility is the right answer
so what is well you need to bring
someone in who's familiar with cleaning
house
yes I mean a woman
a sexist would say
[Applause]
[Music]
terrible
but what you really need is someone who
knows and appreciates science has no
desire for politics and has no problems
dismissing layers of redundant flabby
bureaucracy essentially we need to clone
Elon Musk because he gets it I mean you
run into this problem everywhere in
government it's an administrative
bureaucracy where people fight for
status rather than fight disease and if
you noticed everything about health took
a back seat to enhancing the experts
media footprint being on TV was more
important than fighting TB Dr fauci was
on screen more than our ads for Relief
Factor
and nowhere near as good for you
the only Health he improved was the
health of his ego so it's not just the
pandemic mistakes because we all made
them it's about why there were so many
and so many by the experts why is that
well it's obvious politics infected it
as the CDC indulged the teachers unions
and identity Merchants rather than
giving real Health advice that could
have saved lives suddenly they were
making sweeping pronouncements about
every liberal cause everything became a
Health crisis races of the environment
gun control and yet fentanyl slides
right by them just like covid did just
like obesity just like sugar
so yeah I think it's time for the CDC to
do some serious soul searching if they
have one and maybe come up with a
vaccine that fights politics
[Applause]
guests he's not a cop anymore but I hope
he still stops to Frisk me former NYPD
inspector and founder of Ops dot org all
Moro
wow that was hard
if he's here that means the sale at J
crew must be over oh so the guy Benson
show Guy Benson
her background check has more Flags than
a trump rally Fox News contributor
captive
[Applause]
and the last time he played twister he
killed someone my massive sidekick and
the
[Applause]
end so I just want to put uh I want to
put up guy and Paul could you be up to
put him up side by side isn't this not
wonderful this is the first time in my
career that you that guest came in the
exact same jacket
who wore it better I don't know yeah I
don't know don't answer that
I think you guys look like really hip
real real estate agents you know from
downtown trying to sell a loft and then
you meet you fall in love
who told them you told them
all right let's do this story guy what
do you make of this this is just is this
ever possible can you reset anything in
government first of all can I just say
that we did like the Spider-Man meme in
The Green Room yeah we realized we were
wearing this Brooks Brothers by the way
sponsor us you cowards yes
um so a couple months ago at this point
Governor DeSantis down in Florida rolled
out this plan that he was going to
create like an alternate CDC to look
into the CDC recommendations and people
went crazy over this like he was
besmirching the fine reputation of this
universally respected institution and
it's like do you hear yourselves people
don't trust the CDC anymore I think it
would be healthy to have someone come in
and either Shake It Up in a major way or
do what DeSantis has done create an
alternative to give different ideas and
it should be you know rigorous and
medically based and follow the data
unlike what the CDC did unfortunately
too often on covet I think they should
be uh focused mainly on balance of
nature laughs
Paul welcome to the show first time very
excited we've talked about the CDC I
think what gets me pissed off more than
anything is that the real Health stuff
they miss but then they chase these
political like you know the the
attention-seeking media issues like gun
control and racism climate change well
think about how many people we have
dedicated to this right so you have the
CDC we have fouchies not CDC infectious
and Disease Control the other one was a
niad whatever it's called you have the
Surgeon General yeah Rachel Levine you
have all of these federal health people
none of whom seem to be synchronized
yeah and it just continues to grow right
and yet you had one job and you blew it
so now you got this other and any by the
way anytime you see more than two
Federal acronyms in a story reach for
your wallet yeah all right because you
know where this is going right and so
what do they do they come out and they
say we don't have enough we got to make
this thing bigger we need more computers
we need more more people and then oh by
the way let's move it to DC because
that's a great idea nothing ever goes
wrong inside the belt way so yeah they
never come in and say make it more agile
tear it down less less it's always
bigger and that's the problem here
that's the yeah it can only grow by the
way I didn't know you were from England
I don't get that but I don't get it I
didn't know that is the thickest
Brooklyn accent I've ever heard
Queens
Brooklyn and Queens Brooklyn Queens two
people
he whiz the word today boys and girls is
sarcasm
sarcasm cat you would love to reset all
of government and make it smaller is
this just a pipe dream a crack pipe
dream
okay
um no I I agree I don't think this CDC
needs to do better I think it needs to
do less I don't think the problem was
the people in the CDC so much as people
are the CDC so they're prone to the same
you know
corruption possibilities and the fact
that they're going to make mistakes just
like all humans are so a lot of this
stuff could be done by local officials
who know their communities best and
private researchers who aren't you know
a part of the government
so I don't think it matters who's in
charge I think it needs to be smaller
just these no you guys a bunch of
commies okay
[Applause]
well that was uncalled for a cat
my goodness wow I've been up since 5 30
in the morning I didn't tell you today
you're welcome Fox and Friends oh they
were nice to me there well yeah but I
mean okay
cops and friends
they say oh they say good they say good
morning
good morning they say good to see you
cats
Mom and Dad stop
this is very upsetting
that's why I drink
well in reset make a difference I
think
that's
hilarious
reset like a makeover yes we're going to
change the Seas decays we're going to be
the KDK
whoops my bad we ruined Americans lives
live through our teeth
extorted shamed cost people their jobs
and we're gonna get a makeover we're
going to do we're going to turn it
around you cannot turn around it's time
to go anybody who was working for the
CDC or was with foucher with all
everyone in those programs should be
fired at the very least if not even
being looked at into criminal charges
because they had information that could
have helped and they kept it because why
you said it in monologue that TV was
nice he was throwing pitches out at
baseball games although the worst pitch
I've ever seen in my life and he was he
was on talk shows and he was being
compared to Brad Pitt that's right so
why would he give all that up for the
Saints he betrayed science for himself
so makeover no
euphorically burnt to the ground and
completely started all right
you mean that yeah not literally because
I have to go to HR tomorrow
all right we gotta move on hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else